hey did you see tiger yesterday dude I
was watching it while we were in Georgia
we were in Georgia for the UFC right and
I had a comedy show out there and we
were me and Santino oral actually get on
the screen on Saturday yes we watched it
Friday or was a Friday Saturday Saturday
so I'm try to save anyone yesterday
well whatever days it was right my thing
we watched it two days in a row he was
in the gym every day we were there but
then I got home and I saw it on my phone
I was like holy shit I don't even give a
fuck about golf I know it was big
powerful I made a comeback a huge
comeback but that I mean that's amazing
eleven years later
oh my god great
somebody put on Instagram one of my
quotes oh yeah and I attached to that it
was pretty cool that I love a guy get a
like I love what I said I love a success
story but even more than that I love a
guy fucks his life up and then it gets
it back together again story it's the
greatest yeah it's the greatest how much
much good must feel to that guy ha ha
the world again
and then he like yeah was so messed up
and then the back problems and troubles
and the kids and the wife and the thing
in just 11 years yeah and he didn't stop
working he just went to work and went to
work and went to where he's 11 years
later and so he won a major championship
recently right did anyone win one it was
a big deal he won a major championship
within the last it wasn't a major but it
wasn't it wasn't a major this this was
the first major he's won in 11 years
okay so the other one wasn't a major but
it was a big event yeah it was absurd he
wins that whenever as I Wow
he might be back he can he could fucking
win big tournaments again and then he
just oh it was so cool to see the crowd
just kept building over the weekend and
by yesterday it was massive thousands of
people around the greens isn't hanging
on him ah the relief that you saw just
coming out of him was so great and at
the end like he walks off where as a kid
he was only like 21 when he won the
first time hugging his dad mm-hm at the
edge yeah and now he comes off 11 years
later all this time and his dad's passed
and he's hugging his child his son now
he's the father in the
same spot I was just I was trying not to
cry the whole time oh it was such a
tearjerker what relief people were just
so happy for him such a great story we
do love a comeback why not man you love
a comeback and we we were all flawed
like you were saying before but yeah man
being able to improve that's what that
guy did he got it down and impre--
improved